Now before we get any further, I want to stop
using this word weight. After all we’re
supposed to be talking about pressure. And
pressure is a little bit more fundamental
here than weight. Weight, you see, depends
on the area of this column of air. If we
made it twice as big, we would have had
twice as much air and twice as much weight
. So, why don’t we do this? Why don’t we
do the weight of air and divide it by this area
. And this in fact is exactly what air pressure
is. The weight of air divided by the area
for which we’re talking about. In fact,
pressure in general which we usually label with
a big P is equal to any force – remember
weight is a force, divided by an area.
Okay. So now we can stop using this word weight
and type of pressure. Down at low altitude, we
have high pressure and once we start getting
towards outer space we have low pressure.